[Dave] So question 8 also tests how well you understand the find method
as well as using variables.
The question is assume that text is a variable that holds any string value.
Your goal is to write Python code that prints out the position
of the second occurrence of the string "zip" in text
or prints out -1 if the string "zip" does not occur at least twice in text.
So there are 2 examples.
If text is "zip files are zipped,"
the output should be 14, which is where the second zip appears.
If the text value is "zip files are compressed,"
the output should be -1 since zip only appears once.
And this is a pretty tough question,
so I'm going to give this one a single gold star.